Let's see who else we can talk to.
How about Mark from Framingham?
Mark from Framingham. You're on the air.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Mark, hi.
You recently expressed a wariness about
blanket student debt cancelation, and I'm
just wondering what your reasons for that are.
Yeah. So I've kind of outlined it before,
but I'm glad to sort of do it again. I think
that there should be some debt cancelation and
I'm sort of open to hearing different ideas about
what level of debt cancelation that should be.
I think the problem with just a blanket
debt cancelation for everybody, period,
is that it is going to do a couple of different
things that I don't think are particularly good.
One is there should be some element of it being
need based and need based. I would define it
probably very differently than than some others.
And my threshold for what is need based would be
significant. A lot of people would fall under
that. But I don't see a reason to just go in
and cancel all the debt of everybody who went
to really expensive schools because that's
what they chose to do. They could have gone to a
cheaper school. They could afford to go to a more
expensive school, took on some debt because that's
where they wanted to go. Could have ended up
without debt at a cheaper school. And we're just
going to say here, just take take all the money
and pay it off. I also think that there's people
who have debt forgiveness programs based on the
fields that they are in, if they work a certain
amount of time in a certain underserved area or
whatever the case may be. So we're sort of saying
like, let's throw even more money at a problem
that already has a path to having some degree or
even full debt forgiveness there. And it doesn't
seem to me to make sense to say everyone, student
debt period is forgiven. I want it to be slightly
more targeted than that. I want it to be more than
10 grand. But I don't think it's logical to say
just pay off everybody's debt, period. I've not
seen a good argument as to why we would do that.
You are still to there should be some
responsibility. Like, listen, it's beyond
your control that some schools now cost 70 K.
That's insane. The reason schools cost 70 K
is because it's so easy to get student loans so
the school knows, hey, we'll go from 65 to 70 K
because it's easy to get student loans. We'll get
the money. Then it'll be their problem to figure
out figure out how to pay it off. Like that's
why I want some student loan debt forgiveness.
But to say full, total and complete just doesn't
really make sense to me economically, culturally.
I've not seen a good argument for it. OK,
would you mind if I may be shared a bit of
my perspective, I'm sure. No, please, please.
So the way I see it is a lot of people talk
about how people who hold a lot of student debt
tend to be, on average, higher income because
college graduates on average in the aggregate make
more money. But the way I see it is that higher
income at some point doesn't necessarily mean that
much. If you also have more debt, for instance,
medical school debt on average on top of
undergraduate is two hundred fifty K for law
school, it's one hundred fifty K. And it's kind
of like if I run a business and I want to expand,
I may have increased revenues,
but I also have increased costs.
Yeah. And in fact that this has been studied
and while there is an income premium to college
degrees, the net worth premium is significantly
smaller because you make more money, but you
have more debt. Debt cancels out some of the more
money you have. So, yes, you're absolutely right.
The other thing I would point out is a lot of
college graduates, just because they have to
go where the jobs are, they live in high cost
of living areas. So, you know, a hundred grand
in New York City, according to CNN, Money, is
equivalent to 40 K in Houston. So so it might
sound a lot on paper, but day to day, it's not
really that effect. So and personally, for me,
I tend to lean more towards maybe helping too
many people or otherwise helping people who maybe
don't need that help rather than risk not helping
people who do need that. I totally agree with you.
That's my view with all of these
social welfare programs that
you will always be able to find someone who got a
benefit that you could argue didn't really deserve
it. And I want the line to be where there's a
few people getting it that don't deserve it as
long as everybody that does is getting it. And
so, for example, I'm very open to the idea of
there's a set amount of debt cancelation plus
a multiplier based on some combination of what
is your income and where do you live in
cost of. Like, I'm totally up for that.
It doesn't make sense to me to just say we're
canceling everybody's debt regardless of how much
it is, regardless of how much you make, regardless
regardless of where you live, how long ago you
obtained the debt, how much you know, all this
that I'm not there, but I'm definitely at let's
let's we've got to do more than 10k, OK?
Yeah, I definitely understand where you're
coming from. I had one last question, though.
Sure. You've had people such as Steve Keen
and Stephanie Kelton as well as Dean Baker on.
Yes. These are people who are very critical of the
economic consensus. And I think you've expressed
why we should be skeptical of a lot of mainstream
economics. However, I also think that especially
with covid and climate change, we should listen to
expert consensus on those in those areas.
So is that inconsistent on my part to be
skeptical of the economics profession, but also be
trusting of the consensus in the natural science?
No, I don't think so. I don't think so. And
many check out my interview with Israeli
economist Ariel Rubenstein, who recently explained
economics is a study of what economists believe.
It's not like, for example, rocket science,
climate science, immunology. So, no, I think it's
perfectly reasonable to look at economic thinking
in a different way than we look at, for example,
vaccine vaccine science. I think you're right
to look at them as two different things.
OK, yeah, it's also worth noting that, like I was
listening to what you said earlier about cancer
culture, it's also worth noting because a lot
of conservatives say like, oh, universities are
left leaning, but a lot of billionaires donate a
lot of money to universities with the expectation
that they hire intellectuals who will, for lack
of a better term, serve as mouthpieces for them.
Like Koch brother, like the Koch brothers,
donates a lot of money to MIT. Yeah. And MIT
then becomes reluctant to hire left leaning
economists. So, yeah, it was great to talk to
you again. I really appreciate you taking my call
because I really appreciate speaking with you.
All right. Thanks very much. Great to hear from
you. That is going to do it for calls today.
I apologize to everybody I wasn't able
to get to, but we will try it again and
we'll take a quick break and be back after the
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.